critical oh oh uh are you are you
inspired rain by critical's hair
yeah that's probably what that is yeah
i'm the new i am the new chest jesus
um all right so moist critical is playing the
sicilian which is what we saw him play as well
against ludwig he is comfortable with this opening
i don't know if he prepared specifically but it's
always good to stick to something you know right
definitely definitely if you stick to something
you know then the opening is going to feel a lot
more comfortable and you're probably not going to
lose so much time in the opening as well typically
the opening is the one thing that the players have
prepared and that the players feel quite quite
comfortable with but if that preparation sort of
doesn't go so well or they get surprised or don't
like their position then that psychologically it's
very tough for the players we have knight takes
d4 here then the pawn on e5 is going to be hanging
so critical might actually be able to
win a pawn he can even take the knight
queen takes and queen takes e5 and trade his queen
off the board um okay so he went for this instead
and the computer just had a heart attack here what
is going on move orders are always so difficult
you know what you want to do but you just don't
know the exact order of how you're going to do it
yeah and we know that at all levels but he does
play bishop a3 which the computer does not like
um and the computer doesn't like it do you want
to know what crazy move this computer is smoking
tell me knight b5 knight b nobody's
gonna play knight b5 because
you can't take because the bishop on b7 is
is hanging so that that's all the computer
lines i'm gonna have to see for today i had
to check goes knight b5 now then i think that
we can just shake his hand basically that would
be that would be an amazing move to find by him
yeah this is going to be the touring test um if
i guess touring tests proves that no it would
prove that he's a computer it would be the
opposite of it um if dwight sees it sorry if
rayne wilson i really like the office that's why i
keep saying it i'm so sorry um i totally get that
anyway i think most of most of most of people
just think of him as dwight rook takes e5 is
certainly the most accurate move here um and
you know with reigns play so far i would not
be surprised at all if he takes with the rook here
playing so well wow wow jinx yeah this is i mean
he is a heavy hitter for sure just a blunder no
wait protected by the queen i didn't even notice
he's playing so well yeah yeah and it
is sad to hear um you know kind of i
i think in his voice you can hear that critical
noise the position has been really tough
he sounds a little bit defeated and now rook
takes c6 is gonna win the queen um but hopefully
hopefully he doesn't give up because even if
this game isn't going his way he can come back
in the next one definitely definitely that's the
important thing that he doesn't uh that he doesn't
give up with the next game right do you do you
think reign is going to see rook takes e6 here
i think that ring can see almost
anything no he didn't see that oh
wow he is giving charlie another chance here
um and what charlie can do now is trade off queens
and then develop or give a queen for free oh no
no oh my god no i can't believe i just did that
oh no oh whoops i was so focused on castling oh
whoops uh-oh well what advice would
you give to critical it seems like
he's not in his best form today i know he's very
capable and he can play much better than he did
i think that he should just get over this
game like just sort of like they just laugh
at himself a little bit and you know what happened
and then just say okay rain has won the first game
but there's another game and if i win that game
then i mean it's it's one one and we're taking
it to the next uh to next match so i think that
he just needs to focus on the next one after this
and not dwell too much about this game um maiden
five well i i don't think we're gonna see that but
rain wilson's position is unstoppable now oh and
critical resigned yeah well i i don't blame him
the position was very difficult to save and he
did give it his best i really hope he's able to
shake off the bad feeling from this
loss and come back in the next game
so they're going to start the next game now
e4 d64 all right and also this is not to
um say anything against rain wilson because we
obviously want the best player to win but it would
be great to see both players you know being able
to feel like they were playing their best chess
and they weren't in their heads so that's what
we're hoping to see here and critical is basically
playing what we teach all opening all beginners
to do in the opening put your pawns in the center
develop your pieces and rain wilson is playing a
perk which is a king's indian if it's against a
d4 and it's a very strategic system to play so it
could be very uncomfortable if he hasn't studied
it too much yeah he played it really quickly
and confidently e6 looks like a very strong move
black cannot take i mean he can take and bishop
takes with check oh my god he just lost a piece
that's a piece he's gonna lose the knight on g4
and then critical's king is still in the center
of the board but he should be just up a pure piece
here he should be able to just get his knight and
castle as well pretty pretty nicely after that oh
my gosh i mean uh narediski's pep talks are worth
their weight in gold okay something really
powerful is going on here he just has to
retreat the bishop to any safe square and
he's gonna be okay as long as he doesn't
blitz this out perfect bishop e3 his position
is just much better now he's up a full piece
i i wonder what's happening because you know
rain i i i always get surprised when i see rain
fall for these kinds of mistakes and then i have
to remember he's also human and just because he
is an incredible player doesn't mean that people
don't slip up that's true everybody slips up even
the best of the grandmasters sleep up all the time
so definitely yes the best grandmasters and the
best assistants rayne wilson i'm glad you ended
up getting that management position at the end
um oh gosh did i just give a spoiler
no i didn't okay back to the game um
oh queen of no maybe you cannot go okay that
was a little bit too fast by me i think oh yeah
he he is he's playing very fast
even though he's not the one in time
pressure let's see what critical's
saying he just takes with the knight
but that's good for me i'm up quite a
bit so here take take simplification nice
very nice that's exactly what you should go for
i'm hanging this but it's just a pawn right now
oh i could have just came i
could have just come right in
he did have checks oh my god oh my god i could
have just went right in relax relax charlie
okay oh no oh my god do we have mulligans
in this tournament this is a great position
oh he moved this queen i could
have just went straight in
oh no oh no don't beat yourself up oh
charlie focus what are the odds that
i get away with this if i play this
will it bait him enough to take it
because this is me if i can get this in here
charlie cause he can't block it if i can get
him here oh no he can block right here but it's
still good i need him to stay here actually
how do i get him to stay there how
do i get him to stay realize his time
situation maybe coming over here
he takes i mate i'm running alone
oh i just gave him an out too
but now rain now rain's gonna go knight
c5 i can't believe rain didn't take that
donya's actually smiling through the pc right now
yep how do you play knight
f6 it's just unbelievable
um all right well we're we're back um
we're we're back okay so look overnight
yes he's back these players are they are they
are they friends what's going on here is this
for content i have no idea but but it was
going to take on e6 too oh if he takes on e6
dania might forgive him dania
might forgive him if he takes on e6
g4 okay all right bring the queen out that's
fine he has 25 seconds oh no he's sure to not
lose the brick in any way with something like
king h1 or queen c6 can you go back uh nope he
lost the rook um oh you can go queen g2 or bishop
or bishop d5 no you're right bishop you know no
queen g2 and take the rook you're right i don't
know i suggested that ah okay it is it is um he
can he should still fight here though it's just a
clock situation it's not over oh no he's he's not
looking at the clock oh no oh no go go go go go
six seconds come on just any move just don't flag
uh now rainey is gonna play super fast as
well game is going to give me a heart attack
me too oh wow is there a repetition now
if he wants to but it's not enough for
him because he needs to win exactly he needs to
win and uh there is checkmate queen h3 i don't
know if oh rain missed it rain missed it you're
chilling escape he missed maiden one oh my gosh
all right well critical is i i mean it's a wild
game it's a very well game okay it's going back
oh man oh boy we're gonna have to trade i think
just run just run don't flag don't put queen
f3 no boat as gambits please king's gotta run
yeah i think king h3 would
be checkmate with queen h1
yep good he saw it king g1 he's not
getting mated unfortunately he's in
a worse position but at least he's not getting
mated and he knows that he can't go for a draw
you can tell that critical is turning into a chess
player because he's spending half his time beating
himself up it's a very classic chess player
thing to do i can't kiss everyone just do it
oh no now he's i guess it's a draw because it's
opposite colored bishops but he has no more
winning chances now unless he somehow tricks reign
and gets his pawn on a5 but he'll probably end up
i don't know let's see what happens what do you
think i think that this is it looks like a draw
but at the same time i feel like i need to hold i
don't know different color bishop end game here i
don't know if it's gonna end up in a draw anything
can still happen it's a dance of kings rain wilson
and moist critical the two left in the ballroom
the last ones after everyone's left the stage who
will get the last dance that made no sense just
like this game we're all confused about everything
why not give me five no oh that
was a pawn that had to be no no no
oh no do we have a dania cam i really want to see
the daniel camp i just i'm not saying it's funny
when donya mauls but can we see the dummy what's
he saying it is a draw um still but the problem i
was still hoping maybe he'd win or something okay
draw offer by charlie the rain should just take it
i mean rain should just take it wins the match for
him and it is a draw drawn position but of course
i was still harboring some hopes that
uh perhaps bishop blunder might happen
oh okay well i who do you think would
be sadder if he gets knocked out
critical or his coach i think critical still i
mean chas just feels so somehow personal in a
way and you know you're putting all your effort
into one game and obviously you get kind of sad
when you lose so i think it's it's going to be
more critical but he's taking a while like he's
laughing and smiling yeah all right well they
agreed on the draw um which makes sense because
rain was winning and he's going to make it into
the semi-finals now that he has knocked critical
we are back we're joined by rain wilson and
moist critical rain wilson congratulations you
are making it to the semi-finals critical oh oh uh
are you are you inspired rain by critical's hair
yeah that's probably what that is yeah
i'm the new i am the new chess jesus
oh my gosh critical he's coming for your game
and your personality what do you have to do
no he's gonna have to really commit to it no
showers for three days i gotta be able to see
the grease on the webcam the white t-shirt as
well the white t-shirt as well yeah absolutely
well i tell you that was a nerve-wracking man
these games don't get easier i was stressed
out in that second game man moist critical had me
against the ropes the whole time was all i could
do and um i thought i was gonna win on time but
then he just kind of kept playing a speed game
the whole last part and i couldn't get him on time
and um he just played he played great i got lucky
so i got lucky you accepted the draw i was ready
to just commit to make this like dr strange and
keep you in a time loop all day so i'm glad that
you uh offered a draw i couldn't see a way to
victory was there a way for me to win without that
last set up you guys it's actually a theoretical
draw when you have opposite colored bishops even
if you're up upon and i was actually gonna ask
if you guys have seen any of these kinds of end
games before i've never seen one i i was just
going off pure raw primal neanderthal instincts
an absolute disaster he played a move i'd never
seen before and he rocked me he absol he had me
against the against the lockers in the football
room there i mean i was getting blasted with all
these moves i've never seen you are going to be
going up against benji fishy in the semifinals
he's been one of the top performers i think he's
second by raiding right now how do you feel your
chances are especially with your new hairstyle
well the hair the hair won't let
me down if i'm the new chest jesus
but um uh i don't know i haven't looked at his
games honestly i need to um kind of look at
at his style of play and and get a
little get a little prepped there so
i don't know in a lot of ways you know i'm just
my own worst enemy in this i don't know if you
feel that same way critical because i just my
nerves and i and then the nerves and i can't
quite think straight i can't kind of really think
the way that i normally do in like a 10 minute
game on chess.com where i'm kind of way more like
detached and analytical and i'm able to kind of
see patterns a little better i'm just kind of like
i stumble in a little sometimes i impulsively move
when i shouldn't even though i'm not under any
kind of time rush i got six minutes on the clock
and i'm like you know and just oh yeah um so i'm
kind of my own worst enemy so i want to just get
and this is that's a good good um
this is good character building
you